[Music]
well let's head back to Sri Lanka now to
bring you some breaking news of course
vote counting in that presidential
election was has been underway at
Bernard Smith is life or as in at
Colombo Oh Bernard what what can you
tell us about this foods Allah we've
just been told in the last couple of
minutes that such a prima donna has
conceded victory he says he's offered
his congratulations - got a pyre Roger
Roger Pak sir so got a pirate epoxy
seems to be the winner of this
presidential election not all of the
votes have been counted yet I'm looking
at about three four five six and a half
million counties Oh about half counted
but it seems that most of the votes
votes counted in areas where prima dasu
might hope to get support away from
Rajapaksa have been and gone so there's
little chance it seems of him catching
up with Rajapaksa that's why prima dasu
has offered his congratulations to
Rajapaksa we are waiting to hear from
the Rajapaksa camp no official
announcement yet and just give us a just
to remind our viewers the the the the
the stances of the two men both were
going in as the the other one was the
man to beat but got a pyre Rajapaksa
he's coming in as a challenger
essentially to the to the governing
party is he not yes Rajapaksa is
obviously a member of this family of
politicians his brother Mahinda
Rajapaksa Rajapaksa unexpectedly lost
the presidential election in 2015 so it
seems that this time round the Rajapaksa
have not made the same mistake again
they have worked very hard to get their
vote out in the Sinhala Buddhist
majority community that attempt to get
the vote out seems to have paid paid off
75 percent of Sri Lanka's population is
Sinhala Buddhist prema dasa also
Buddhist and was getting support from
that community mainly from rural more
working-class areas and he was hoping he
could pull in enough support from the
tamil manya Artesia and Muslim
minorities to take the edge off
Rajapaksa it hasn't doesn't seem to have
work in the north fremitus have got a
huge share of the tamil vote but that
alone hasn't been enough it seems to
take victory away from Rajapaksa so with
prima das are conceding that he's lost
and congratulating Rajapaksa gotta buy
Rajapaksa on his victory it's a return
of the ratchet paksa brothers to
front-line government in Sri Lanka and
Bernhard's this presidential vote of
course coming after those devastating
attacks on Easter Sunday when over 200
people were killed in those attacks just
how big a factor have security issues
been in this election well it was that
if that suicide attack that killed 263
people when eight bombers targeted
churches and hotels in sri lanka it was
that that prompted got a pirate japax to
announce he was going to run for the
presidency and in the months since that
that bomb explosion a terrible failure
in the terms of the current ruling
government government has been exposed
in the intelligence reports it was told
in intelligence reports that a bombing
was likely to happen but because of the
dysfunction and the enmity between the
current president and the prime minister
nobody paid proper attention to those
reports and the suicide bombings went
ahead so Rajapaksa was able to play on
that and he promised Sri Lankans our
return to stability and security and
that seems to have won the day with the
majority of Sri Lankan voters ok
Bernhard Smith there live for us in
Colombo thank you very much indeed